the royal family is focusing on
traditions for easter weekend whether
it's church service or celebrating a
group of heroes the world needed to be
reminded of the power of the human
spirit
first off it's no ordinary weekend for
prince george and princess charlotte
alongside parents prince william and
kate middleton the kiddos attend their
first easter sunday service
while walking to st george's chapel in
windsor castle the family marks a
special occasion by color coordinating
their ensembles
william and george don blue suits
while kate wears a blue coat and a
matching hat with young charlotte
wearing a blue sweater and a blue floral
dress
the duke and duchess of cambridge also
take to twitter sharing this image of
their custom stationery and the caption
says quote wishing happy easter to our
followers
meanwhile prince harry and meghan markle
hit the field for a good cause hello
everybody
and welcome to the hague
finally
god i've missed you all the couple is in
the netherlands for the 2022 invictus
games
the world needed to be reminded of the
power of the human spirit
the ability to heal
and the strength of resilience that
allows us to recover
and come back stronger
founded by the duke of sussex himself
the sporting event focuses on wounded
servicemen and women providing them a
chance to compete in various sporting
activities
to incorporate a fitting fun fact harry
and megan actually made their couple's
debut at the 2017 invictus games it's
also a grand return for the ceremony
after two years following its
cancellation in 2020 due to the global
pandemic
and i tell you
i tell you what and people around the
world have missed this
the boundless humility
the compassion
and the friendship that is invictus
harry and megan's trip also kicked off
with an important homecoming etsy
confirmed they made a pit stop to visit
queen elizabeth on thursday
a spokesperson tells e.t the couple
visited her majesty at windsor castle
it's a major update for harry and megan
marking their first joint visit to the
uk since 2020 when the couple stepped
down from their senior positions in the
royal family
of course the reunion coincides with a
sad milestone for the family the one
year anniversary of prince philip's
death at age 99. so i think a lot of
people are wondering why he can't be
there for such an important family
occasion harry was noticeably absent
from the service last month we
understand the reason prince harry won't
be attending is because of security and
the situation as far as harry is
concerned is that he will not have
police protection over here and
therefore he doesn't feel safe bringing
his family over to britain i think the
optics of harry not coming over to
england for the service of thanksgiving
for his beloved late grandfather is not
good in the context of them coming over
just weeks later for the opening of the
invictus game in the netherlands it
continues the narrative of a rift of a
fallout and a discord at the heart of
the royal family at a time really when
the queen needs her family the most
[Music]